so wanna hear a killer prank
this is a really funny prank you're
gonna like this prank
uh ailing nurse alleges to have swapped
5 000 babies within 12 years
for fun for fun
well it's a good it's a good prank bro
that's earth it's a good that's not
tyler perry
um elizabeth may you confesses her sins
i thought who's that uh female
comedian oliver black one oh
black monique monique monique yeah
uh yeah she's like brandy's friend of
militia nurses are
seen as caregivers in the hospital and
patients are supposed to feel safe and
taken care of and they're
in their charge however some nurses are
proven to be the devil in human form
a zambian nurse elizabeth
that's her name has confessed her sins
on her sick bed as she asked god's
forgiveness
the zambian observer reported the nurse
i am so sorry for switching your babies
i had a good joke i did
it as a joke i had a joke i can't say it
but it was a good joke what i can't say
here i'll tell you real quick just so
you could i got to get out of my system
let me just real quick
i think you can get away with that
though yeah even these nurses
can't tell the babies
who knows which baby is which baby i do
not know which baby has which baby
black panther all i know is he is black
and he has i do not know the difference
how do you know the difference i see
black
and then they just who's the head nurse
is the [ __ ] who's the japanese guy
oh man how do i even tell these people
apart
no beta they're all looking like a brac
come on
oh criminal baby you see what i mean
i hire japanese people they are much
smarter than us
and they cannot tell baby apart if you
cannot tell baby apart
how can i tell baby apart
not even japanese man i hire i hire him
for lots of money and hino telepapad
so he's just in the background ranting
about criminals
she said i have terminal cancer and i
know i will be dying soon
i wish to confess my sins before god and
before
all affected people especially those who
were given birth at uth during my
service
according to my uh according uh she said
why did i switch your baby
i do not know according to the elderly
woman she is now born again and did not
want to hide anything
that would stop her from visiting the
land of honey and milk
the kenyan the canyon nurse and youtuber
well she's like a prank youtuber
i did it for my youtube channel my
youtube channel
i want to make big youtube channel so i
do prank
switching baby prank i have nothing to
hide in the 12 years i worked at the
maternity ward at uth
i swapped close to 5 000 babies
[Laughter]
added that it became a habit and she
used to do it for fun
which has now acknowledged that she has
sinned against god
and zambians and would want them to
forgive her i know i sinned against god
and may he forgive me
uh and may he forgive me uh for that i
also am asking zambians to forgive me
for the evil things i was doing to
innocent children i have cops and
faithful coppers
oh i have caused some faithful couples
to divorce
that have gotten dna tests holy [ __ ] you
know i don't even think about that
just kidding we do not get married in
africa
i have caused many mothers to breastfeed
children who are not theirs biologically
i don't want to go to hell for that and
i'm really sorry i have sinned a lot
please forgive me she begged
me i don't think that's how it works
though it's just like
you don't just do horrible things and
then don't make up for them and then go
yeah by the way i did all these things
also added that the kids born between
1983 and 1995
at the hospital should check themselves
particularly
before they wreck themselves
particularly
before they wreck themselves yourself
um good reference such a heartbreaking
good reference and i'm being such a
child today
at the hospital should check themselves
particularly if they look different from
their other siblings
if you were born in uth between the
years of 1983 1995 chances are your
parents may not be your biological
parents
i had developed the habit of swapping
newly born babies
just for fun she said so take a good
look at your siblings if for example
everyone is light and you are a [ __ ]
her words
you are that child and i am really sorry
for that remember even if you have
darker skin you are a problem
she added it's strange how someone can
think swapping babies is fun
so that's the story
uh so for any any of our listeners that
might be in zambia
in case you're from there leave what are
you still doing there no and by the way
everybody's like no
that is how christianity works
it is but it's not like bro no at no
point has anybody ever said like
if you do this kind of a horrible thing
and then never tell anyone about it and
never do any good in the world and then
just wait till you get cancer and go
yeah by the way i'm gonna come clean i
did all these terrible things
well i'm good now like that's just i get
it but that that is
that is exactly what christianity
teaches yeah but it's not
if you're on your death bed and you say
i know it's a cheater
i don't know what you're saying it's a
cheat code i hear you your motivation
there is
[ __ ] nonsense right i'm dying now i
should [ __ ] face it
yeah [ __ ] out of here i don't think you
get to live 99
of your life as [ __ ] you just wait right
till the end and go oh boy i'm sick
sorry jesus i'm pretty sure i'm not
saying
all people who uh who do that on their
deathbed
are bad i'm just saying that a lot of
them are full of [ __ ] and i don't think
that that should be
honored there are some people that are
dying
genuinely reflecting and go ah [ __ ] man
i really did [ __ ] up and i'm sorry
but i don't think going like somebody
called the newspaper
i want to tell them my story and then
just mr craig goes
my bad jesus yeah you know sorry
it's just